on vient ici la police de longueuil
travaillait sur cette histoire depuis
des années un homme qui sortait à peine
de prison après avoir purgé une peine
pour agression sexuelle vient d'être
arrêté de nouveau edouard stéphane
georgescu est maintenant accusé d'avoir
agressé au moins 11 femmes à brossard
entre 2007 et 2012
jean-sébastien cloutier la police de
longueuil parle d'une des plus grande
enquête pour retrouver un prédateur
sexuel
ben oui vous l'avez dit 2007 à 2012 et
ça a continué par la suite à montréal en
2013 pourrait y avoir aussi d'autres
victimes dont qu'edouard stefan george
escou 31 ans vous allez voir des photos
de lui une en 2008 une autre prise il y
a quelques jours donc aurait agressé
onze jeunes femmes de 13 à 29 ans autour
du site où je me trouve ce choix au
terminus d'autobus panama à brossard sa
façon d'opérer était la suivante à la
tombée de la nuit tôt ou plus tard en
soirée ils ciblaient son éventuelle
victime la suivait l'interpellé lui
demander par exemple une indications
routières et là ils l'enlevait et
l'agressait l'homme a comparu cet après
midi au palais de justice de longueuil
pour faire face à 32 chefs d'accusation
dont agression sexuelle armée au début
c'était un couteau à la fin un fusil
ensuite bon séquestration tentative
d'enlèvement et cetera faut dire qu'au
cours des dernières années la police de
l'agglomération de longueuil avait
diffusé un portrait robot de lui sans
résultat et ça a débloqué patrice l'an
dernier il ya une femme qui a été
agressée par l'homme à montréal en avril
2013 et elle a ensuite reconnu le
portrait robot
on a fait le lien avec lui par les
traces de l'adn bref il a été arrêté à
sa sortie de la prison de bordeaux
vendredi matin donc le 14 février on
parle de onze victimes potentielles mais
peut-être beaucoup plus le souci je sais
écouter le porte parole de la police
un acte similaire ou par géographie nous
sommes en mesure de penser qu'il
pourrait y avoir
minimalement une quinzaine d'autres
dossiers qu'on a présentement entre les
mains
donc monsieur joël jusqu'où pourra être
l'auteur c'est toujours sous enquête à
ce moment ci
alors l'inspecteur robert parle d'une
quinzaine minimalement peut-être
d'autres comme malheureusement il
pourrait y en avoir plus
la police donc laissé un numéro de
téléphone pour le public qui aurait des
informations pertinentes
le 4 5 046 trois sets 2 1 1
l'homme comparaîtra à nouveau palais de
justice de longueuil le 11 mars pour son
enquête sur cautionnement
jean-sébastien y avait eu un chauffeur
d'autobus sur la rive-sud corrigez moi
si je me trompe qui ressemblait au
portrait robot à l'époque que l'on avait
diffusé et lui avaient été harcelés dans
son milieu de travail cetera et s'étale
jusqu'au suicide
donc c'est une histoire dont on parle
depuis des années effectivement 2010 ça
et c'est effectivement une bien triste
histoire liée à cette arrestation en
quelque sorte aujourd'hui ouais merci
jean sébastien au revoir au revoir